las comunidades remotas del estado de
amazonas en brasil recibieron con júbilo
la llegada de las primeras vacunas
contra el cob y 19 de la empresa astra
zéneca trabajadores de la salud viajaron
hasta allí para inmunizar a decenas de
adultos mayores que viven en las zonas
rurales la prioridad son los que pasan
de 80 años y los indígenas de unas 265
aldeas en la región
estoy muy feliz porque es lo que
esperaba y espero que todo salga bien
la amazonía tiene la tasa de mortalidad
por coronavirus más alta de todo el país
y es además el lugar donde surgió la
variante brasileña de joven 19 que
comparte algunas características con
otras variantes del reino unido y
sudáfrica y que se cree son más
contagiosas a esto se suma una segunda
ola de contagios que ha colapsado el
sistema de salud que hemos perdido a
tantos ancianos y jóvenes
esta es una esperanza de que las cosas
van a cambiar y a mejorar
la situación preocupa a los países
vecinos ante la escasez de oxígeno el
presidente venezolano dijo que enviaría
a camiones cargados hacia los estados
brasileños de roraima y amazonas
fronterizos con venezuela adicionales a
los enviados a mediados de enero las
autoridades colombianas también por lo
expuestas que se ven las comunidades
indígenas que viven en las periferias de
leticia donde ya se han confirmado casos
de la nueva variante